hey good afternoon before I thank Bruce
I want to thank Jeff brands el the
entire TD community for the opportunity
to talk with you over the next couple
days more than an honor for me it's a
pleasure to be with so many friends of
mine of our city and our great
university here in New Haven I want to
also thank Bruce less for his
introduction and I could say this to
Bruce it was so hopelessly incomplete
Bruce there's so much more you could
have said about me but less for his
introduction and more for his friendship
and guidance over the years he and Chris
Alexander's commitment to their adopted
city is extraordinary and unlike me
Bruce and Kris were not born here
they're here by choice and I'm grateful
for all that you guys do for the city so
thanks so much and I look forward to
talking with you all in a few minutes
when you will use the microphones if you
have questions it seemed appropriate for
me to talk about cities and civic
infrastructure and that's what I thought
about from the moment Jeff extended me
this opportunity and particularly wanted
to do so in something that we knew was
going to happen about this time which is
the substance of ensuring that New Haven
public school students have the
aspiration for college that their
college ready once they matriculate into
school and therefore connected to
lifelong earning I will tell you that I
am convinced it is the key wealth
creation violence reduction and city
building opportunity of our time now
first they are for civic on
infrastructure and by civic
infrastructure what I mean are the
things around which we organize our
lives and the lives of our community now
not all lessons are learned in the
classroom so let me tell you how how
John came to learn about civic
infrastructure I am a lifelong City
resident is Bruce
I grew up in the Morris cove
neighborhood of New Haven now my family
in fact moved to Morris Cove in 1960 as
that special and unique kind of New
Haven refugee we were not escaping
political or religious persecution
rather was the forest relocation that
was so common to America in the 1950s
and 60s and which was particularly
destructive to New Haven and so many
other cities my family were refugees
from New Haven urban renewal i-91
construction took my grandmother's house
we are four households and three
generations of the stephanos had lived
together for decades live together if if
not exactly peace and harmony at least
in relative coexistence with one another
we lived on East Street between state
and Humphrey here's a photo of my
grandmother's house it's now an I 91
overpass our neighborhood and the whole
social and dynamic fabric that derived
from a dense urban place was destroyed
it no longer exists in our families
instance has happened in neighborhoods
across New Haven attempts to build the
new Civic infrastructure actually
destroyed it first lesson learned about
civic infrastructure is the cure can be
worse than the disease so anyways Morris
Cove is on the other side of the
Quinnipiac bridge from where we are
today so growing up I didn't have much
occasion to come to this side of the
city in fact it wasn't until I was 13 or
14 years old that I first came on to
this campus I had three de Stefano
cousins who actually attended Yale
College and I came over one day with my
dad to visit now as a new haven police
officer of his time my father had rather
definite
use of yale college and its inhabitants
so by virtue of both parental
inclination and pretty mediocre
academics Yale was not a factor in that
part of my future and truth be told to
my younger eyes it was a very different
part of New Haven in fact a part from
New Haven rather than a part of New
Haven you could see it you could feel it
the idea that the university was an
integral part piece of the whole of the
city did not exist in those days today
that has changed in my years since that
first visit to campus that change is a
good thing for which I will say Rick
Levin and so many others are much to be
credited and I think it's gotten to the
point that it's something we will never
return to and never should change back
to our future is bound up in one another
it's the same future lesson learned
always define community and citizenship
in the broadest fashion possible to
include not just some but everybody have
a big vision of what we are now the next
part of my lesson about civic
infrastructure did occur at school as
part of my own college going experience
which was at the University of
Connecticut unfortunately those were the
days when Yale still could defeat us in
basketball in football happily here two
things have changed for the better an
enduring source of amazement for me
about attending UConn in the late 1970s
was the tuition or really the lack of it
tuition fees room and board four
thousand dollars for a full year was
something I and lots of other kids were
able to earn during the summer and
during winter break and really didn't
even think very much about it back in
the
days nor do I ever recall a time when
going to college was a question in my
life we were middle class second
generation Americans and we were going
to be first-generation college-goers not
really a topic of discussion with mom
and dad if you know what I mean in those
days if you work hard if you display the
aspiration in the persistence the means
existed for a college and lifelong
earnings but since that time college is
not nearly as affordable for most
Americans the nation has fallen from
first in the percentage of our
population who are college graduates and
at the same time write a college degree
is more essential than ever for lifelong
success in New Haven we were building
highways when we first should have been
about the business of building human
capital the academic success of kids
there are college readiness and their
persistence in college going is the
moonshot of our time it is the best
wealth creation and violence reduction
strategy that we can hope to ever pursue
consider three sets of data since 1992
the number of Americans employed with
high school degrees or less has fallen
from 47 million Americans to 44 million
drop of seven percent at the same time
over that time the number of Americans
employed with some college or more has
grown from 53 a million Americans 278
million Americans an increase of
forty-seven percent the numbers are
pretty straightforward if you want a job
get to college second the more education
you have the less likely you are to be
unemployed a lot less likely
particularly in this tough economy and
finally the higher level of educational
attainment the less likely you are to be
in jail if we want a safe city
we will dramatically increase college
going among our young people I was
trying to figure out who the one percent
of those jailed with bachelor's degree
were I figured they were my colleague
mayor's actually the civic
infrastructure to rebuild a resurgent
America run straight through the front
doors of our nation's universities and
colleges and most likely those front
doors are to be found in America's
cities so what about cities now the last
time I gave a speech of some length
about cities was in 2003 in fact it was
november 2003 and i was president of the
National League of Cities I was at the
national press club in washington at the
time and the talk was being broadcast on
c-span which really didn't mean anything
until we got to the last question now
have you ever been to one of these
things are seen these at the end of the
speech the president of the club
collects the questions on these little
these little three by five index cards
and ask the questions to the speaker so
I'm out of town no one really knows me
there that can vote for me so I'm kind
of Frank and loose and i'm bout through
the whole thing and we get to the last
question and the last question is is the
question that any new haven politician
wants to avoid because it requires a
response of transparency and conviction
on a matter that really divides people
in new haven so I'm here at this thing
I'm almost out last question at the
Press Club they asked me so mayor is it
Sally's or Pepe's now I freeze this is a
question of significance and consequence
for me is it Sally's on the one hand or
is it puppies so I ask you to think
about that question is that what we are
about as a city great are beets
it's sort of like you can get a
hamburger here or you can come to New
Haven and of course get this it's not
just about a beets and hamburgers really
that's just shorthand it's shorthand for
how we and others see the city and see
ourselves it's it's a kind of nickname
but it's not who we are in the end
cities are about a lot more than aa
beats and hamburgers and so let me
explain in our lives in overtime of this
nation cities are the wealth multipliers
cities create our middle class our
markets in our competitiveness they have
done this generation after generation
without fail in America cities test and
define our values as a nation and as a
people cities are the place the place we
come together to determine our potential
and possibilities as individuals it's
the place that enables to us to do
together for ourselves the things we
cannot do alone and in the process of
doing so social and economic mobility
occur his wealth and personal
development accrue cities cities when
married to good sound Civic
infrastructure is the community highway
we build to perfect ourselves in which
we become a nation bound up in a shared
set of values and short a place where we
become Americans and the most poetic
description of cities I ever heard was
spoken in 1988 just a few blocks from
here at Yale Commons December 1988 the
25th anniversary of Hill health centers
the speaker said cities are viewed as
the stimulating and valuable centers of
human activity because when disparate
energies are harnessed extraordinary
achievement flourishes think of cities
great and small
and much more than commerce and law in
trade will come to mind though they will
so will the names of great hospitals and
libraries and newspapers and
universities so also will theaters and
museums and opera houses and restaurants
and galleries and cathedrals so we'll
stadia and arenas in short not simply
commerce but culture not simply work but
leisure not simply as the Romans said
nego TM but otium not simply that which
ennoble us but also that which perfex us
such as for ever been the purpose of a
city to make us not the best that nature
can make us but the best that we
humankind adding art to major can make
us so said barge amati former president
of Yale before he got an important and
meaningful job as commissioner of
baseball now at first glance thinking
about Bart's words you'd think he'd be
taught he was talking about the built
space great hospitals and libraries and
universities theaters museums houses
restaurants galleries Cathedral stadia
arena that was not what he was talking
about if that's what he was talking
about we should go out and build another
Coliseum for a hockey club what really
it's about was this cities are viewed is
the most stimulating and valuable
centers of human activity because when
disparate energies read that to be
density are harnessed extraordinary
achievement flourishes the whole is more
than the sum of the parts to make us not
the best that nature can make us but the
best that we human kind adding art 28
your nature can make us doing together
what we can't do alone the built space
in the final analysis is like the ah
beats and the hamburgers it's incidental
the Civic infrastructure that counts is
not the building capital it's the human
capital
and that's what cities are and always
have been about and if we're going to
remain a great nation that's what our
future has to be all about so so over
the last two years New Haven has been
engaged in a powerful and dramatic
effort at public school change and last
week the university in the city took a
wonderful step forward on behalf of
young people across the city for which
this city and university share common
purpose last week the New Haven promise
scholarship program was launched
promises the college-going component of
New Haven school change initiative the
individual benefits of increasing the
number of new haven college graduates is
astounding it is amazing students with
college degrees are almost four times
less likely to be unemployed than high
school dropouts and have annual wages
two and a half times more on average if
New Haven promise moves the needle on
its three goals cultivating an
aspiration for college education in New
Haven Public Schools building community
and parental engagement and growing
economic development in the city of New
Haven by just one percent a year we
could initially see a talent dividend of
some 647 million dollars so last week
our city made a promise to build
something more ambitious than an urban
renewal project last Tuesday we told our
new haven public school student students
that if they did two things work hard
academically graduating from high school
with the 3.0 GPA and second display good
Civic behavior meaning have a positive
disciplinary record complete a 40-hour
community service requirement it meet
ninety percent attendance or better if
they did those two things New Haven
promise will fund their tuition for any
in state public university or college
period now it's not a handout promise is
not designed for or entitled to be and
are intended to be an entitlement
students will have to work hard to earn
their grades and stay focused on
positive behavior and good choices but
do those two things and promise will see
to it that they have the resources to
compete successfully anywhere and if we
if our city does this and does nothing
else we will fail fail just as large as
urban renewal failed and remaking our
city 50 years ago it's not enough to put
a pot of gold at the end of the rainbow
for the kids who are going to reach it
anyway promise will only succeed if we
make all new haven kids be the best that
they can be it can only succeed if we
put in place the infrastructure the
supports and the tools for a
superhighway not just a limited access
road for the very few who already know
the way only with supports only with
robust Civic support can these kids in
our city be the very best it can be the
promise scholarship program announced
last week must be accompanied by some
things the development of the aspiration
and all New Haven kids and their
families that a college degree is a
prerequisite to a successful life that
this is something that these kids and
their families can do the we as a
community are going to work hard hard
together and is it necessary to see that
they have every chance of making it to
and ultimately through college and that
promise is a core component of a radical
and uncompromising commitment to a
broader school change initiative so week
ago today we announced the new haven
promise scholarship and tomorrow we will
announce the new haven promise
partnership the partnership will be an
additional umbrella of funders
organizations employers in people who
organize themselves is a community of
adults around promise kids and their
families the
partnership will work on our streets and
in our schools it will be phased in over
the next five years as we phase in the
scholarship program commencing with
pilot initiatives this spring New Haven
promised partnership will launch with
the following three supports first the
partnership will work with classroom
teachers in the high schools by guiding
students through the college process
these supports for our high school
students will be provided by a partner
by the name of college summit and will
focus on academic excellence
self-advocacy career to college
connections college 101 and financial
awareness the partnership will work with
the new haven promise to increase the
number of promise scholarships awarded
to graduating seniors as well as
increasing the college enrollment rates
college persistence rates in college
graduation rates second second the
partnership will message interrupt
develop curriculum for our students
starting in pre-kindergarten and
continuing through eighth grade before
transition to the even more intensive
high school curriculums and supports the
pre-k to a curriculum will seek to
cultivate an aspiration for college
education as soon as the school district
receives kids you will take into
consideration non cognitive learning and
incorporate key milestones that students
and their parents must meet in order to
better prepare them for high school
finally finally New Haven promise will
unleash College core college core will
enlist all adults and organizations in
New Haven all who share promises mission
on behalf of these kids in two ways
first college core in the high schools
college core in the high schools will be
trained on college 101 curriculum and
college essay writing skills so
volunteers may further support College
summits work in the high schools in
second college core in the community
consisting of local undergraduate
students
fresh themselves from the college-going
process and partnered with City adults
will canvass our communities and teams
to ignite the aspirations and
expectation for a college education and
the parents and all of our KH students
we will go door to door to door together
together these efforts will initiate
nurture and ultimately support
college-going aspiration and the work of
promise kids and their families you
haven promise needs to be more than a
scholarship program to fulfill its
mission ultimately in the end promise
has to be a citywide commitment it can't
be a university commitment it needs to
be a citywide commitment a citywide
civic enterprises that organizes all of
New Haven's adults around its young
people and enterprise centered on
traditional values of hard work
persistence and initiative a new haven
promise will be about everybody who
lives in New Haven regardless of income
regardless of immigration status and
regardless of what past family history
his told kids about what they can or
cannot be perhaps you've heard of the
concept of tikkun olam to heal the
universe it's the idea that God created
the universe but did not finish it or
make it perfect and that therefore we
each of us have an obligation toward
improving the world that the task of
healing each other is a spiritual moral
in an individual conception of Justice
in that it is in this mending mission
that lends meaning to our own existence
ultimately promise is more than an
investment in these kids ultimately it's
about
each and every one of us about our
optimism in ourselves in our own future
it's about rejecting being a city of
victims in a choice to be a city of
America's future a city with an
ascendant future in Haven promise
scholarship and New Haven promise
partnership are too strong legs that
will speed us on that journey one of
optimism and accomplishment it's why
each and every one of us in this city
are confident that even in the worst of
economic times it is the best of times
to test ourselves our character our
determination in our conviction these
are the best of times to succeed I look
forward to taking this journey with this
entire community on behalf of these kids
to build human infrastructure instead of
the other kind thank you so much and I
want to talk to you so tell me